여기 현대 라이브러리에 현대에서도 산
거 또 현대 라이브러리 뮤직
라이브러리랑 그 현대 바이닐도 있고
그래서 두 개나 있고
[음악]
그래서 그때 이제 장동건씨 건물이
그거는 고저가 그나마 초입이어 가지고
건물이 다 보이긴 하잖아요. 그래서
좀 되게 메리트가 있었는데맞도 좀
있다 보겠지만 폭스바겐 나가고 지금
포로시 들어와 있으니까 그 지금 또
시간이 열흘려서 보면은 또 지금 되게
괜찮아요. 어 지금 잘산 거 같아요.
여러분 코너에 한남동 카페
초입이었으면 필사람 얘기하신 대로
바에 여기 차리 건물 있고 지금
시간에는 외국인들이 이쪽에 더 많은
거 같긴 하거든요. 보이시는 것처럼
사람들이 많이 있긴 하네요. 그리고
에피소드하는요 안쪽에 나리 식당이라고
혹시 들어보셨죠? 예. 왜냐하면 제가
그때 서울에 처음 왔을 때 저희가
바로 뒤에 살았거든요. 그때 냉동
삼겹살이 1인분에 12,000원이었어
가지고 아 지금 얼마예요? 지금 뭐
모르겠어요. 근데 10년 전에 그
12,000원했던 걸 보고 저
충격이었었거 비싸가지고 여기 한번가
보시죠. 예.
[음악]
가보시죠. 무신사 저쪽에도 들어와
있네. 아 무신사 진짜 많긴 하네.
성수동도 많고 이태원에도 그리고 저기
이면에는 그 대기업 청수님들 많이
사. 그렇죠. 이태원에는 사실은
유빌리지 이전에 이태원 뒤쪽이 더
부자들 원래 많이 살았던 동네 하니까
사실은. 근데 이면에 원래 뭐였는지
아세요? 원래 그거 있잖아요.
장례식장이 아니라 그 뭐죠? 무덤
무덤 아 무덤 무덤 무덤 그래서 저기
땅파면은 가끔씩 나오잖아요. 그래가
하나 공사현장 멈췄다고 알고 있어요.
삼성권 맞아 맞 지금 6월 엄청 많이
6월 엄청 나와서 공사 다 스톱돼
가지고 그러니까 저희 공사할 때 되게
조심해야 돼요. 요게 요게 이제
장동광 아 이게 장동광 건물인데
포르쉐로 바뀌네 예 폭스바겐 나오고
포르쉐 들어왔는데
[음악]
그래서 지금 여기 나원이랑 그 꼼대가
손길 사이에 이제 카페 거리에 와
있는데 여기 사실 다 주택가였어요.
원래 그니까 사실 제가이 바로 옆집에
살았었거든요. 제가 서울에 쳐 봤을
때 그게 10년 11년 전이긴 하니까
그때 여기는 뭐 진짜 사실 아무것도
없었어요. 그렇죠. 그렇죠. 그
나인원 들어오고 나서 좀 바뀐 거
같아요. 정확한 시점이 언제냐면
나인원 한남 들어온다고 해서 그게
호재가 반영되지 않았었는데 아까도
보셨겠지만 나인원 한남 후문이
저쪽으로 난다고 이야기가 그게 공사
개우가 나오면서 이제 그러면이 나인
한남 사람들이 사실 이쪽으로 유입될
거다라고 생각을 그렇게 저희도
브리핑하고 했었는데 실상은 그쪽
사람들 사는 사람들은 다 강남에서
소비를 하고 그거를 보러 사람들이
오는 그런 형태가 된 거라고 좀
생각했습니다. 뭐 외국인들 오거나
그냥 재밌게 뭐 데이터 하기 좋을 것
같긴 해. 조금은 뭐 성수 느낌도
나고. 여기 한남동인데 조금 고급
더운 느낌이 있으니까. 맞아요.
맞아요. 그래서 일단 어디 잠깐 카페
가서 네. 카페 가서 예. 앉아
가지고 좀 자세히 얘기해 보시. 예.
이야기를 하시죠.
카페 왔는데 여기 되게 좋은데요.
이태원이랑 확실하게 좀 분위기 다른
거 같아요. 그러니까요. 그
여성분들이 오기 좋은 곳이에요. 진짜
저도 외국에 살아봤지만 제가
외국인이라고 치면 낮에는 여기 와서
그냥 뭐 식사하고 뭐 카페 갔다가 해
떨어지면 이태웅을 좀 넘어가서 어떻게
반분할 즐길 수 있는 뭐 그렇게 하면
좀 괜찮을 것 같긴 하거든요. 우리
섹션이 길어 가지고 저희는 지금
이태원에서부터 녹강진역까지만 왔지만
좀 더 넓게 있는 경리단길도 갈 수
있고 저 뒤쪽에 해방촌 HBC까지도
갈 수 있으니까 요즘에 제가 나이가
들어서 그런지 몰라도 속담을 좀
좋아하긴 하거든요. 옛말 틀린 거
없다 이런 얘기면 좋아하는데 부동산은
좀 백문이 불열견이다. 그냥 여러
자료를 뭐 주거나 이런 거 기사를
통해 듣거나 뭐 SNS 통해 듣는
듣는 것보다 한번 와서이 직접 보면이
상권이 어떻게 흘러가는지 그걸
정확하게 파악할 수도 있고 저희는
그걸 대신해서 영상에 담는 거긴
하니까 무조건 현장에 와서 현장에
답이 있다고 생각하긴 합니다.
이태원에 워낙 오래 사셨고 한남동에도
오래 사셨고 그러니까 제가 여기
살고이 뒤에서 살았을 저 7년
살았었거든요. 근데 이렇게 한남동이
많이 바뀌는 걸 보면 저희 제가 갈던
빌라 주인는 지금 때동 버색 때돈
버색 두체 있으 저 일단 뭐
이태원이랑 한남동 쪽 돌아봤는데 진짜
확실히 좀 차이가 있는 거 같아요.
네. 확실하게 분위브 자체가 다르긴
하니까 그죠 그죠 뭔가 각권마다
특징이 있긴 하지만 또 연결되는
부분도 있고 밤에는 이제 이태 문화를
즐기려는 젊은 사람들이 많이 있고
그리고 오전에는 상대적으로
이태현보다는 한남동이 훨씬 많 이쪽
허버스토어도 많고 뮤직
라이브러리라든지 어떻게 보면 제가
조금 경기당끼리 조금 세했던 이유
자체는 어떻게 보면 문화 시설이
없었다고 생각하긴 하거든요. 근데
이쪽 공간에는 지금 뭐 팝스토어도
많이 있고 뮤지컬 라이브러리 있고 뭐
카페도 이렇게 잘 되어 있고 둘러볼
곳이 많으니까 사람들이 상대적으로
시간을 정체할 수 있는 곳이 많다고
생각 들거든요. 그래서 확실하게
퇴원은 좀 놀고 나가는 곳이라는이
동네 약간 사람들이 좀 머무를 수
있는 예 그런 곳이라고 생각이
드네요. 저도 동일하게 생각하고 점점
더 상권이 양극화되는 거 두 개가
동시에 뭔가 될 순 없고 어찌 됐든
지금 한남동이 워낙 좋기 때문에
경리당이 사실 살아나기 쉽지 않을 아
경리단은 사실 제가 저번주자 한번
가봤거든요. 사람이 일도 없습니다.
개미 한 마리가 없습니다. 경기는
개미는 있을 것 같 개미가 없어요.
사람이 없다이 뜻인 거죠. 제가
개미가 없어요. 거기 제가 다음에
개미 있는지 한번 찾아볼게.
알겠습니다. 그래서 한번 뭐이 부분
참고하시면 좋을 거 같고 그 무엇보다
뭐 얘기 많이 듣는 거보다 직접 와서
또 느끼는게 제일 중요해서 뭐이 영상
한번 보시고 참고가 되는 것도
중요하지만 한번 직접 와서 네. 직접
와서 보는게 제일 좋을 거 같고 자기
자신의 인사이트와 견물을 넓히는게
가장 투자하기 전 단계라고
생각합니다. 제가이 채널에 도움이
된다고 하면 언제든지 불러 주시면
나올 수 있도록 하겠습니다. 반응
보고 반응 보고 아 반응보
오늘 마지막이지 아 오늘 마지막 아
알겠습니다. 알겠습니다.네 그래서
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요. 어
다음 시간에도 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]